[Musik]
danke danke ganz schön dankeschön
dankeschön ich weiß ich wurde nicht
vermisst
ich habe mir so einen drink gemacht zu
stehen aus apfel karotte sellerie rote
beete kurkuma und hafer milch
es schlägt auf jeden fall gesund dabei
herzlich willkommen heute zu einem neuen
video meine lieben freunde ich hoffe
euch geht's gut ich hoffe ihr seid
gesäumt warum gebe ich unfassbar viel
geld für klamotten aus wenn ich dann
doch nur mein eigenes merchandise trage
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht was ich machen soll in
meiner hand ich kann wenn ich will gar
nicht aussieht wie die - wollen
was ist los natürlich wieder alles nach
vorne
ich hoffe auf jeden fall euch geht's gut
meine lieben freunde ich hoffe ihr seid
alle gesund und munter und ich habe in
sechs tagen geburt
ich versuche mich zunehmend gesünder zu
ernähren weil ich mir einfach denke dann
leg ich länger ich hab da auch ein glas
strohhalm jetzt gekauft glas ströme sind
so das ding finde ich einfach
plastikschuhe hände sind je nicht mit
mir aber papst rahel müssen dann die
darum so kämen dort an der lippe fest
und ist wenn diese matsch und brechen
sind durch wieder bitte über glas
strohhalme diesem bild das ist einfach
eine spülmaschine packen wieder
verwenden diesen extrem sexy aus aber
wenn es die natürlich in welchen
restaurants oder bars gäbe werden die
glaube ich alle direkt geklaut ein paar
sekunden später
[Musik]
das ist gar nicht passiert ahu noch
alles dran ist eine gute perspektive
sondern ja herzlich willkommen zu dem
neuen video auf einem kanal luca badoer
dix ich vertraue dem schreiben nicht
mehr ein bisschen warum ich mich heute
so geld angezogen habe richtig ich habe
auch keine ahnung aber ich glaube es
liegt daran dass sich die sonne
vermisste alle influenza sind trat
irgendwo in dubai irgendwo in kroatien
wo man gefühlt bayern kann wie sonst was
in südamerika und hamburg regen ich
heute einfach mal auf eine intensive
suche betrieben nach solarien in hamburg
und die haben einfach alle geschlossen
und wenn ich nach solarien suche dann
heißt das schon was weil ich hatte
meinen mit übelsten platzangst
panikattacke in eine tonart und weil ich
wusste dass das team seine sicht ist ich
glaube dass ich so und ich waren 80 mal
fordern kommt da irgendwie feuerwehr er
wahrscheinlich vorher werden gehabt da
kommt eben wieder notdienst rein und
dann leg ich dann irgendwie so auf dem
boden mit einer panikattacke kommen gar
nicht glauben nackt gucken wir straight
im ein arschloch
ich habe auch wieder so ein bisschen mit
sport angefangen ich war gestern abend
zum beispiel beim joggen ich weiß nicht
ob das eine gute idee ist oder später
bereuen ich kämpfe oder sowas ein bein
beim letzten taxi gerufen
aber hey ich bin meinen gesunden news
sondern wie läuft eigentlich
sportunterricht gerade in corona zeiten
up where we talk somit mathe deutsch
englisch geschichte solche fächern also
das macht auch komplett sinn aber sport
macht ihr dann alle klemmen oder macht
man ja was noch so passiert ich habe
schon verloren
ich habe keine ahnung wie man handschuhe
verlieren kann allerdings haben den
spaziergang gemacht um die alster und
beide male die alster in hamburg ist
dieser riesige nebenfluss von der lbbw
dingsbums mitteln der stadt von der
santa zugefroren die als ist einfach
zugefrorenen haben wird man dürfe
allerdings nicht auf die alster drauf
gehen weil ringsherum ganz viel polizei
war und immer wirklich mit zum megafon
beruf mal abonniert kontraste auf
herzlich willkommen crafter abonniert
laser luca auf youtube haben wieder alle
gerufen und die leute sind trotzdem auf
die halbzeit gegangen
doch da sind wirklich extrem viele leute
auf die alster gegangen obwohl von der
polizei verboten wurde und unter anderem
auch eine person einfach mit einem
kinderwagen wenn du alles okay ist eine
schöne aber das kind dann auch noch mit
in den tod zieht ist vielleicht nicht so
das allerneueste so edel dass vögel
einfach im fliegen kann ich kann doch
auch nicht während ich laufe dann auf
jeden fall meine spaziergang gute zurück
gelaufen und habe sondern ist auch bode
guckt wo die sachen scheiterte liegen
können dann hat mich halt in 50 jährige
deutsche hat angesprochen meint es
versuchen sie was und ich nehme man also
nee ich schauen wir einfach
leidenschaftlich gern diese kieselsteine
ja am der familie hobby war extrem metal
meinte dann halt ja ich kann ihn auf
jeden fall helfen was haben sie denn
verloren ist er handschuhe sind also das
kann ja nicht weit weg sein
dagegen verlor ist es so ein richtiger
ein anspruch das kann ich nicht wechseln
weil willst du das wissen an hättest
dann noch weiter richtige mexiko vor
drei monaten verloren habe ich ein
handschuh noch ein vernünftiges getränk
lieder und was hat euch dieses video
hier überhaupt das kann ich hier auf
play gedrückt habe dass ich wenig
aufträge durch aufnahme geklickt aber
warum hat ihr aufträge druck eigentlich
wollte ich auch noch nicht aufbauen habe
hatte ich habe keine steckdose hier von
daher steht es jetzt einfach so ins
depot apropos deco ein bild von mir
runtergefallen es war unsinnig die
letzten tage in hamburg und dieses bild
was hier hängen ist halt direkt neben
meiner haustür und es ist wirklich
einfach unter die gewinnzone
das ist ordentlich schief hier
indirektes erreicht so wie ich gerne
ordentlich tief in die ritze von verdis
mühe sonst so real wie die tier gerade
mit diesen london um bald ich werde
langsam wirklich verbot
ich gehe jeden tag spazieren und
meistens allein weil ich keine freunde
habt ihr das wenn eure familie irgendwie
besuch zu hause bekommen und die
verstecke zu vier stunden lange warum
zimmer und gibt dann irgendwann nach
oben
ich ordne aber zurück zum wichtigen 1
verlorene handschuhen ich habe dann
wirklich damit abgeschlossen was ich
denn irgendwie wieder fit werde ich weiß
wenn ich was ihn jemand mit einem
einzelnen
handschuh machen will aber okay
verpasste ich hab gesagt bekommt ich
habe mir schon werden wir arbeiten jetzt
gemeinsam unserer fitness freunde okay
die stufen challenge ins leben jeden tag
[Musik]
3000 us let's go und so begann bei der
reise zu den 3008 ich musste durch den
monsun und wusste dass dieser weg
steinig und schwer
doch ich habe ihnen dennoch auf mich
genommen und 3000 jobs erfolgreich
beenden
all das ist schon ne menge und jetzt
kann auch auf jeden fall ein bisschen
dauern aber es ist gut für euren körper
ich will so eine wir müssen uns
eigentlich einen linksschwenk ich habe
so ein neues protein pulver gekauft das
soll wirklich überhaupt keine werbung
sein aber das ist halt komplett vegan
das ist ein pflanz rockland proteam bild
herford mit cover gluten friedliche
politik beim glauben wissen auch wo es
kaum laut 9000 das riecht wie diese
türkischen kaugummis auf den druck aus
und ist seither nur so einen backstein
[Musik]
man kann nicht so war
also mein magen befindet sich gerade
mischung aus kurkuma apfel rote beete
irgendwie hafer milch und wasser mit
proteinpflanzen ich hab wirklich
abschnitt überhaupt keine ahnung was ich
mit dem heutigen video hier bezwecken
wollte ich habe einfach nur gedacht hey
ich habs weg und das wollte ich mit dem
video
[Musik]